>> Tucker: IN THE PAST TWO
MONTHS MORE THAN HALF A
DOZEN AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED OR ATTACKED WHILE IN
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
WE HAVE TEAMED UP WITH "FOX
& FRIENDS" AND SENT GRIFF
JENKINS DOWN THERE TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT IS
HAPPENING EXACTLY.
PEOPLE ON THE ISLAND JOINS
US EXCLUSIVELY LIVE FROM THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC TONIGHT.
GRIFF?
>> HEY, TUCKER.
GOOD EVENING.
WHEN IT COMES TO FINDING
ANSWERS, WE FIND THAT THE
OFFICIALS HERE ARE MOSTLY
STONEWALLING US.
HOTELS AREN'T GOING ON
CAMERA TO TALK TO US.
AND THE TOURISM MINISTER IS
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
SO WE TOOK THE HUNT FOR
THESE ANSWERS STRAIGHT TO
THE TOP MODENA IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC, HE HAS BEEN IN
OFFICE SINCE 2012.
HE WAS THE GROUND BREAKING
EVENT YESTERDAY.
SO WE WENT WITH OUR
QUESTIONS.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
WATCH.
MR. PRESIDENT -- I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THE RECENT
DEATHS OF FOUR AMERICANS
HERE IN RESORT.
MR. PRESIDENT, JUST A MEANT,
SIR?
NOW, ONE OF THE GENTLEMAN
YOU SEE THERE, TUCKER, THAT
THE PRESIDENT MEDINA IS
TALKING TO IS ONE OF THE
WEALTHIEST INVESTORS IN THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
HE SPOKE TO ME AFTERWARDS IS
HE WORRIED ABOUT THE IMPACT
THESE DEATHS MAY HAVE ON
TOURISM.
HERE IS SOME OF WHAT HE HAD
TO SAY.
LISTEN.
>> WHEN PEOPLE COME TO ALL
INEXCLUSIVE.
PEOPLE HAVE A TENDENCY TO
DRINK AND EAT MORE THAN
OFTEN.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE PROBLEM
BEGINS BECAUSE WHEN YOU GET
EVERYTHING FREE, THEN YOU A
MAKE A PARTY OUT OF IT.
SO, SOMETIMES PEOPLE MAY NOT
BE CAPABLE OF DRINKING AND
EATING AS MUCH AND THAT'S
WHY YOU HAVE [INAUDIBLE]
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM OF THE
MINI BAR.
PRESIDENT MEDINA IS A VERY
RESPONSIBLE MAN.
AND I'M SURE HE IS INVOLVED
PERSONALLY SUPERVISING
MAKING SURE THAT ALL THESE
COMES TO AN END AND HE GETS
A CLEAR PICTURE OF WHY THAT
HAPPENED.
>> NOW, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MINI BAR, YOU HEARD HIM
MENTION IT THERE THE HARD
ROCK CASINO IN PUNTA CANA WE
SHOWED THAT YOU VIDEO OF THE
MINI BAR WHERE HAD YOU FULL
FIFTH OF LIQUOR IN THERE
ISSUING A STATEMENT SENDING
SINCERIST CONDOLENCES OF THE
FAMILY OF MR. WALLACE AND
DAVID HARRISON AND SAID THE
ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
SAYING THIS, QUOTE:  WE CAN
ASSURE YOU THE SAFETY AND
HEALTH OF OUR GUEST IS NOW
AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
WE CURRENTLY IMPLEMENT
BEVERAGE PROTOCOLS INCLUDING
PURCHASING SEALED AND
UNOPENED PRODUCTS FROM
LICENSED AND REPUTABLE
VENDORS AS WELL AS DAILY
INSPECTIONS OF ALL PRODUCTS
SOLD THROUGHOUT THE HOTEL
BARS AND IN-ROOM LIQUOR
DISPENSERS.
AT LEAST THE HARD ROCK
RESPONDING TO OUR
INVESTIGATION.
YOU KNOW, IT IS GOING TO BE
THE FINAL TOXICOLOGY AND
PATHOLOGY REPORTS OF THE
LAST FOUR INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE DIED HERE AND THE
MECIOUSZ THAT HAVE DIED
HERE.
CAN I ALSO ADD TO THIS THE
MOTEL RESORT BEHIND ME,
TUCKER, THIS IS WHERE THAT
MARYLAND COUPLE EDWARD
HOLMES AND CYNTHIA DAY WERE
UNRESPONSIVE.
DIDN'T CHECK OUT ON TIME.
FOUND DEAD IN THEIR ROOM ON
MAY 30TH.
THEIR ATTORNEY TELLING ME
ABOUT 30 MINUTES AGO THEY
JUST GOT THE BODIES BACK
TODAY TO MARYLAND.
HE WILL DO HIS OWN
INDEPENDENT AUTOPSY AND
TOXICOLOGY REPORTS.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT THOSE
RESULTS TELL US WHEN THEY'RE
AVAILABLE.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: SO THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE MR. RAINIERI MAY HAVE
EATEN THEMSELVES TO DEATH
BECAUSE THE FOOD WAS FREE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, HE IS
CLEARLY A BILLIONAIRE ON THE
ISLAND THAT HAS A BIG STAKE
IN ALL OF THIS.
HE POINTED OUT, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: DIDN'T SEEM A
PLAUSIBLE EXPLANATION.
PRETTY UNBELIEVABLE
INTERVIEW.
>> IT TELLS US ONE THING,
TUCKER THAT IS THAT THEY ARE
SCRAMBLING IN THE WAKE OF
THESE TRAGIC DEATHS AND
CERTAINLY HOPE NO MORE
HAPPEN.